all right let's do it jen let's do it
let's do a list all right
let's do this good fight companion
yesterday oh so my favorite one so i'm
so glad you did it
you guys look like you were having a
great time great rampage jackson how
great is rampage have you ever have you
never met him before i have no i have
i've spent some time with him he's a
national treasure you know what i love
about it is he doesn't know like our
dynamic or your dynamic so we're talking
about like gay stuff he's like
i mean i'm just listening
you know brian we're talking about tommy
if you're in bryce talking about he's
like attractive yeah and you see ramp
you know refugees don't play that yeah
he is
if uh that's what you're into that's
fine but he's still got a sense of humor
he still gets it and i was like oh this
is great rampage doesn't know that we
[ __ ] around non-stop great stories oh
his pride story is legendary
and i will say this too and i and i hate
saying it hate saying
you're strong
yeah
you're strong sure
for a normal dude no you're a strong guy
bradley strong bradley martin's strong
badly strong bradley martin now we're
now on different proteins though
different proteins
proteins now hold on
however i might take one scoop of
whatever protein he's on he's on
all the scoops now i don't know
about that i don't know i don't either i
don't know or wait for a while
you guys taking different weight
proteins yeah he might be taking iceland
now here's the thing yeah he's jacked
the man can jump out of a pool four and
a half foot pool the man can has a
vertical that's that's
have you seen how high you can jump
and then he's dead lifting 750 pounds
which is on his instagram and he's
squatting on a hoverboard 350 pounds
some of the [ __ ] he does is weird yeah
yeah he's weird good dude though right
that's the first time you met him yeah
and then he let ryan garcia work his
body his core
for i don't know
a minute or more that's ryan's thing
everybody yeah without padding without
padding
yeah he did to friends and got him too
they're just like it's ryan's thing like
you go on a show he let branson kind of
no no no francis let him punch him oh
yeah come on
[Laughter]
yeah he's a very very he's a friend that
was a fun fight company long though four
something hours as long as that's boxing
for you some of those fights are just a
little bit difficult
and even even if they had been all
knockouts leaning up to the main event
boxing they don't care the weight
they'll just wait it out i i have a
couple things a couple opinions to about
um
about
jake paul and who he should fight and i
have some opinions about who he should
not fight okay
i don't want him to fight
i don't want him to fight certain guys
i don't i
tell me who you want before you go down
the rabbit hole
saying who you don't want fights easy
yeah
who who would you like him to fight
i'd like to i'd like him to fight nate
diaz
not nick diaz
and i think if he fights nick diaz and
he especially if he fights jorge mosby
doll very bad idea
see hora is a better fight from the nick
or nate diaz oh no no i oh no look at
what jorge did tonight you're talking
about mma oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait nick are you talking
about nate you said nate i'm talking
about nate diaz the idea i think is he
he has an easier time with nate
um because i don't know that nate hits
as hard it's but it doesn't matter it's
nate's pressure they think how tired he
was against woodley and woodley really
didn't throw they don't get tired eight
is gonna be in your grill
so if you don't knock him out that first
second round and you go eight rounds
then that fifth six seven eight is going
to be a nightmare this is true
but look how many punches they threw
yeah it's going to be quadruple that
with nate yeah and nate nate um although
and nate's nate's forte i mean he's
obviously jiu-jitsu he's uh great off
his back but he box boxes yeah the only
thing is i would say is that that i i am
really impressed with how hard
jake hits so i i don't know that if nate
is in this grill like that i don't know
if anybody's head can take that kind of
pressure so knocked out once yeah um i i
so nick
i think nate's better fight i think nick
is real trouble and i think i think
jorge is real trouble i think i think a
guy i think he has to stay away from
guys like kevin gaslam guys like even
even the guy who beat this is stupid
likely the those ufc fights bad ideas
tell me who you want to fight because
all those are unrealistic because
they're under ufc contract
so dana's gonna have to play ball with
showtime and they hate each other okay
it could like a conor could happen
because it's such a big payday and dana
likes money so does espinoza so that
could possibly happen down the road but
unless it's a massive massive payday day
is connor too small for him
better boxer but is he two uh yeah he's
too small yeah but i don't want to see i
don't want to see somebody who's
i don't want to see somebody
i'm caught i'm torn because i love this
kid and i don't want to see him get beat
up by somebody who's really good i'm not
interested in that i love his guts
boxing for three years dude but that's
why you should stick with these mma guys
correct i don't want to see him fight
some
he could fight him and fight this
he'd beat the shadow i would love to see
he would after watching last night he'd
be done
um so who give me you haven't given me
one legit matchup
because i can't think of anybody that
anderson silva
anderson's help would be a good matchup
and i think anderson will probably beat
him
right you would think i think so let's
just see why did julio chavez jr i mean
that's a big deal and anderson let's see
how he looks anderson now
40 something six yeah probably 46 47
maybe even older and then
damn i'm good i would love to see that
that's the fight i'd like to see
uh
the smart next step like you're fighting
an actual like striking expert instead
of just these wrestlers who also fight
correct that would be that would be
that's the idea like you'd be
is nick diaz too much for him
i see if you care about them i don't
like those diaz brothers they can box
dude and i do care about them they can
box yes
that's the thing i don't want to see
this kid
take a whole bunch of head trauma i love
what he's doing for the sport and he's
fun and i love these challenges would
you watch would you buy another woodley
rematch i would i don't well i don't
care i would but i'm i don't care i
think we'd see it again i think we might
see this it wouldn't be the same result
i think that time is on jake's side and
time is not on tyrant's side yeah i
think for jake they can't probably just
need to move on from that like all right
you did that now now let's fight for the
next like a real strike we won that
fight and square yeah i give woodley and
you know i'm on i'm
biased towards willy i you had three
rounds okay me too i would too but real
realistically probably won two right
so i'm i'm i'm i'm done with that
um but yeah but there's besides
and then there's tommy fury there's a
woodley rematch
any of these ufc names you guys
mentioned you got to realize the ufc
would have to be in on the deal and
that's such a nice yeah
is there anybody who's
a retired boxer who's now 50
collecting see i don't know if you can i
don't know if you can still keep doing
that either yeah like fighting older
guys like people are making fun of them
yeah it gets boring like woodley makes
sense you're just retired you know he's
taken seriously for sure man
what 43 i think it's like no 30 39 39
right yeah at least 39.
still
i thought woodley uh he just like you
know these people out there like oh it
was fixed
he had him rock didn't go in for the
kill then you don't know what you're
talking about if you've ever seen
woodley ever ever fight especially his
last five fights he's just fights
tentative he just doesn't pull the
trigger that's just his style yeah
yeah
so i i don't know what they do with jake
if you want to like wait wait it out and
wait for someone to come about he could
do that or there's the woodley rematch
or uh the easy payday's tommy fury
well yeah
and and or or he
does one more fight and moves on
no moves on the wall too much money he
probably made 20 mil last night a lot of
money
are you really gonna take too much
damage no how much damage does it take
in practice though how much that's the
price
maybe is this the price is it worth the
thing to play the 15 million a fight
i guess it is and he's starting and he's
24 yeah
his sparring partners don't really throw
i saw like a couple of videos his though
that they do bubba he didn't get ready
by should he sway he trains with world
championships yeah look at the i just i
know i don't care what you see on social
media i'm telling you i know from his
team yes he goes with world champion
you're not getting good like that you
want to get good this fast in three
years if he's fighting [ __ ] he's taking
it he's taking shots like the video like
have you seen the video seem like
beating up someone's smart partners like
starching them yep that's just for the
grim yeah i i heard he gets [ __ ] up in
practice he's fighting real dudes yeah
he you couldn't get that good this fast
with fighting bumps correct
his team's pushing him in there they
have to be
and i just don't know what he
i wouldn't like we talked about last
night like what's his ceiling you know
like i'm so curious like i think he he's
his last fights against his brother they
make all the money in the world and then
move on to whatever the [ __ ] they want
to do is his brother training as hard as
he is oh yeah logan yeah you saw him
against floyd yeah yeah
has he got another fight coming up no no
rumors was a logan vs anderson but
i think jake jake's the one the guy's
gonna go after yeah
um it's interesting what they're doing
though it's very interesting i think
he's
i think he puts people on notice he's i
like his ambition i think he get last
night he got like we found out more
about jake paul who did woodley
woodley's woodley yeah he's a legend
hall of famer yeah with jake it's like
yeah kid's pretty [ __ ] good man he
can yeah and he can he's an outsider for
him to be able to do that in three years
stupid 100 but again what's the ceiling
i don't know his team has to you know
that's his team
you know just like bradley they just
don't i think he knows because he's
around real boxers but like you know
like bradley martin was like i'll fight
dylan dannis like okay
okay you know like i know you
bench seven thousand pounds delay it's
just it's just not the same thing well
yeah when you get in there it's just
it's just starting and then this one you
can't breathe and you're really and then
it's his team like after that woodley
fight you know i don't know his team you
know are they like dude that was too
easy
let's go for a [ __ ] hula chavez jr
and then it's going to get dicey
they're smart though this is all just
money they're just printing julio chavez
jr even though he lost to [ __ ]
anderson is a legit boxer
yeah just wasn't his dad that's his and
he had no heart he was lazy you know
but you know i mean and by the way
people say he's lazy but you know to be
the kid of a great champion like that
and grow up with money the way he did in
privilege i i've always been impressed
with him it's hard it's [ __ ] hard to
to to have options and you'll still be a
fighter on his level
yeah he did a decent job yeah yes he did
he's way tougher than he should you
would not want him versus jake
i think it's silly it'd be a terrible
idea yeah and again by the way i don't
i'm not interested in that okay so
chavez beats him well no [ __ ] he said
he's had a hundred fights he's been
boxing since he was in diapers yeah so
and then jake gets all [ __ ] up and
stuff i'm not interested yeah i don't i
like i like these fights i thought the
tower woodley thing was perfect it's
entertaining yeah yes and it was a good
fight man he looked great
you know for for somebody who's been
boxing for 10 minutes did you because i
left right away i had to get home did
you guys get out late
yeah well me and me and uh bradley
started talking
and then uh
and then josh thompson who's just great
we're just hanging out you missed a good
time in la jolla man i would i would
move there if i could do my songs i'd
move there oh yeah i love it out there
is there anything not to like about it
the weather is always perfect it's just
clean
it's just perfect there's no mass if you
want to wear a mask wear a mask if not
don't it's just great man yeah it's
amazing man
i know you all saw me uh writing for the
first time with the thick boy bite club
san diego chapter and there's a picture
on my legs are juicy like a lady make
some juicy ass thighs and you know what
a lot of it is thanks to peloton because
listen man do the pandemic i didn't want
to go work out around people either i
want to keep my thick ass at home get on
a bike but not just any bike the peloton
bike can do from my home they got great
workouts you can do a 20 minute workout
30 minutes 45 minutes yoga weights we
got pilates they got everything man they
got it all and it's fun you pick some of
your favorite trainers all right you
have some of your favorite trainers
mine's robin you can pick country music
playlists hip-hop playlists they have a
90s they have 80s they got it all man
you can just cruise you can do
tabatas they can do all sorts of things
like there's leaderboards you interact
with the whole community there it's
fantastic with peloton bike there's
nothing like working out from home learn
more at 1peloton.com new members can try
peloton classes for free for 30 days at
onepeloton.com app terms apply that's
onepelton.com
e l o o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t o n dot com my
profile name on there is thick prez
thick boy
prez you'll find me on there holler at
your boy stay thick stay on a bike yo
man with today's low interest rates it's
a great time to refinance your student
loans we got you man earnest offers low
rate student loan refinancing you can
check your rate risk free in just two
minutes with earnest you get flexible
payments you can pick your loan term all
right if you have questions you can even
talk to a real human at earnest for help
isn't it time you stop feeling
overwhelmed by student debt earnest is
offering you guys a hundred dollar cash
bonus refinance your student debt at
earnest.com fighter terms conditions
apply now ernest is giving you guys a
hundred dollar bonus refinance your
student loans at earnest.com fighter
terms conditions apply once again
you get a hundred dollar cash bonus when
you visit earnest.com fighter to
refinance your student loan not
available in all states terms conditions
apply
it's so nice out there
oh we did the the
would you would you get bored
not me i'm a homebody dude like i don't
yeah i don't go out at night i don't
like going to dinner it's like perfect
for a person for me it's i'm that's my
ideal [ __ ] that's where eventually if
you know the plan is everything goes
right i'll end up there
i'm not leaving california but i'd go
there i get it
yeah it's [ __ ] nice we did the the
thick boy bike club san diego chapter
and my boy uh jason kidd not the
basketball player another guy uh put it
on dude
we meet there i don't know a few hundred
people there and they donate bikes that
can we raise money donate bikes to kids
underprivileged kids right and then we
ride out but it was just like
you know i i didn't promote it this guy
put it together they do them and this
jason guy is such a nice [ __ ] person
he saw his kid has autism his dad had
dementia and he was like in the he was
like during the pandemic dude i like had
horrible depression i just need to do
something so i saw you riding bikes i
started getting [ __ ] really into
bikes but they're like in the crew you
see that cruiser yeah it's always jay's
bike coming in
don't be mad the legs
but so where so they but they ride like
peach cruise this cruise around town on
beach cruises there's no gears right
there's no gears like that but yeah i
knew it wasn't like my do it because i
ride specialized mountain bikes and road
by like real bikes they they cruise
around for a great benefit and great
cause and it's all fun but i knew it was
gonna be different when he goes shop get
up here man oh my god don't call me out
dude and he gets me i think he goes all
right man he goes you know we're happy
to have brandon here and donate the
bikes and he goes today's not about what
set you from blood [ __ ] it doesn't
matter
he goes here we just ride bikes i looked
at jaggo are we in a biker okay
i was like are we in a legitimate
bicycle game
i was like which one's bloods i was like
what the [ __ ] you're sad it's like 1995
i'm doing mad tv and i've never done tv
before and i've never not really been in
la i mean i've been there once before
but i'm just in la and i'm doing a tv
show and i'm on a set and i didn't know
anything and and i never forgot there
was a kid who was wearing he was this
regular kid he was like a costume guy or
whatever and he was in a he had a red
red shirt and a red [ __ ] bandana not
a yeah like a bandana and something like
that and uh these [ __ ] people came up
who were secure and they go hey we don't
feel comfortable with him with that
stuff man he's he's he's wearing he's
rep repping red right now and we're in
blue territory and i don't know what the
[ __ ] they were talking about you thought
it was like the cardinals versus the
cubs yes that was all that stuff it's
like and i was like huh what do you mean
and i was like well just get a cup and
they're like no
it's just a different body you're like
wait what i didn't know what the [ __ ]
was going on there you did that movie
you had to yeah was that bloodshed shot
callers yeah
the security was all blood
shot colors just hung there now it's
less i think they don't now they don't
rep the red and blue though as much
yeah
all right let's stay out of this pop-up
yeah yeah yeah you don't want to i
remember when i was so active yeah still
pretty active don't wear those colors
forgot that i remember you'd be fine
he'd be fine if you wore those colors
yeah you'd be good but you don't you're
just like just like a [ __ ]
dude i remember when i was a kid i wear
that cups hat all the time with the
indians out the indian that was red like
i wear now i wear that because it
reminds me of my childhood and then the
cubs had i drew a beer you know i'm like
seven i draw a little beer prince on the
bill with a blue hat in the red sea and
my friend who's black i went to his
house for like a play date or whatever
just went over there and as soon as i we
we walk in you know the mom's like all
right you guys are gonna go down the
store later and she was oh honey honey
hey no no you're not wearing blue around
here and i was like what that's what i
was like what are you talking about she
goes i don't want you get hurt damn i
was like over my cubs hat i i've had
[ __ ] paw prints on the front she's
like you just can't wear around here she
was your mom would kill me if you got
hurt
i remember thinking like that that part
yeah
that part used to be intense like the
the color thing where they but like like
i mean now they kind of just wear you
know whatever whatever but like i mean
they're still active you know what i
mean dude me my friends we didn't even
notice that we were walking late by
buckingham mall in aurora late saturday
night we had nothing to do you're just
walking around went to red robin because
the waitress was hot i'm like in ninth
grade and i got this new old navy jacket
and it was red and then my other friend
had a red thing on and with me you know
[ __ ] three white boys dude yeah and
we're walking and this [ __ ] black
dude comes running up with us with his
hand underneath his uh hoodie he goes
why you all flamed up because i was like
right
up and i was like flamed up and i was
like well i meant out of breath i was
like because we started running when we
saw you he's like why are you all flamed
up he's like take that [ __ ] off right
now he's like you're in blood whatever
blah blah and i was like oh [ __ ] oh my
god i was like oh my god this is really
going down she's like take that [ __ ] off
in my friend who's just he's like this
the biggest soy boy you've ever seen
played like tennis which back then
wasn't cool i remember he took us off
real fast and i was like all right i
took mine off like jesus calm down dude
and then when i saw the gun i'm like oh
hell no and then he's like spit on that
[ __ ] and he's like he's like spit on
that [ __ ] you know i was like
faking it and i look over my friends
going
i'll get a big ass yeah i was like dude
that's your jacket though
i never let him live with it down too i
go remember when you're so scared you
hocked a little blue over your [ __ ]
jacket shot over the dumber that's how i
know that's even me being like kind of
joking about like dude calm down
i've
one of my first times in la uh i'm
[ __ ] white guy and i we go to this
party my friend takes me to some party
just girls everywhere and then we come
out and my buddy who's black was a
writer and he was with his girl
and uh
and he's he grew up in crenshaw
so
we come out and this this mercedes full
of like it was like
four black dudes and they were kind of
like they were
they looked older they were probably
like i don't know they look like they
were
late 20s
and the guy just goes like this guy goes
he says something like
uh i like your girl or something like
that or whatever and my friend goes ha
ha i like you i like your wheels man he
goes yeah yeah all right and and he's
but he's he's being disrespectful he's
like looking at his girl so you know me
i'm i'm like hey bud
i'm like i'm not afraid of you [ __ ]
guys because i'm going to punch you in
the face when i was young i really was
that idiotic are you ready for it so i'm
like this i'm going like this and i'm
going
i'm looking at him like this
but they're not noticing me
and he and he's from crenshaw and
they're having a conversation but he's a
smart ass but he's being super super
respectful he's laughing and he's going
man i love man i'm jealous of your car
man all right yeah they pull off right
and i go i go what do you don't be
afraid of those guys i'll fight those
[ __ ] guys they're [ __ ] being
disrespectful for your girl and he goes
hey brian hey brian
this is los angeles they don't give a
[ __ ] about they're not going to fight
you they're going to shoot you and you
know what i said i go but there's so
many people around they're going to
shoot you oh they don't do you know how
many people are in jail because they
shot
somebody went do you think that yeah
like it was such a wake-up call to me
and a bloody nose now you're gonna get
shot in the face i wish kyle was in here
kyle caught another thick fly on his web
you don't say last night she's a diamond
no uh saturday night saturday friday
night friday night it was the night the
night i got there friday yeah friday or
friday night yeah you start carrying a
camera around i know i'm a mustache i
know
he's walking down people like notice
them and [ __ ] mm-hmm oh and jay [ __ ] on
a scooter oh
you shot him it's good no no like he
fell [ __ ] felt [ __ ] like he
that's a big dude on his hands and knees
and his knuckle you could see like the
white of his knuckle because it ripped
the skin back i said something i mean he
was so mad so we're going down we're
going to stk the steakhouse down in san
diego and we're driving down there
and my my bike was fully powered so i
was like flying by everybody and i'm
going they have those little lights on
the front so i just turn around checking
everybody i see three lights oh yeah
that's cool going out here
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i turn around i just see two lights
i go oh and uh my boy greg the car guy's
up there i'm like hold on and we go back
and jay's so mad
jay selma kicking the [ __ ] escape
what did he hit he [ __ ] up his watch
his new grand second watch yeah he uh it
didn't have breaks and the light went
from yellow to red and we kept going and
he was like no but he can't slow down so
you turned real sharp and went to cuckoo
nothing more painful we're in the car no
and stopping scraping your [ __ ] on the
street dude
hey we're in the car in a way so how can
i go jason said a word since he crashed
and she goes what the [ __ ] you want me
to say
whoa
hey
hey i don't own bird scooter
that said whoa he told me he goes i
wanted to slam it so bad
yeah he has real anger
god damn what the [ __ ]
the one the one thing that people never
talk about is when you go to like greece
you go to the islands you go to bermuda
they they rent mopeds yeah and when
you're in rome you get a moped dangerous
i was at the hospital my buddy we got in
a car accident my buddy jimmy burke had
to get his shoulder he's all [ __ ] up
and i stood there while and i'm not
they brought one
young person in after another from
all mopeds you go to bermuda you go to
the i talked to the doctors there
if you want i'll tell you what i can do
your favorite you could you could run a
moped you've never ridden one so what
you should do is instead of running the
moped let me take a sander to your skin
in a baseball bat and it's like that
because you may as well just go ahead
yeah
the [ __ ] injuries suck dude
suck
i like your guy greg
greg yes yeah car guy yeah dude my this
girl i know from from you didn't even go
to the car we went to cars and coffee
out there which i'll do
it might be uh the one in malibu is
pretty [ __ ] big but it's a confined
area wait so it's similar to what you
take the tiger to what's cars
yeah all the well no it's like a
gathering every sunday uh there it was i
think saturday's in san diego and
sunday's in malibu cars and coffee so
anyone with dope cars like and choose
the same guys everybody goes there with
their ferraris and lambos and mclaren
yeah they talk like those motorcycle
cops you see that yeah that's correct
yeah yeah you know that's my thing no
well i i like because like
i was going to meet you at 10 a.m to go
that's this is me yeah i just don't like
it well it's weird to me when people are
irrigated because they own a lamborghini
i want to be like [ __ ] you didn't make
it
you you have nothing to do with it
yeah in in utah where my dad is a member
of his club sometimes they'll bring
like these crazy they brought a four
million dollar car there yeah bugatti
yeah four million dollars those are the
bugattis f4 why are they is that how
much they are oh yeah i didn't believe
it yeah pagnoggies or whatever they're
[ __ ] three minutes but they'll have
they'll bring their ferraris and they're
all just kind of hanging out and what's
amazing is usually older dudes older
white guys and uh ferrari outfits
they they rock they rock the whole get
up and that'll bump me out it bumps me
out a little bit man they're in the full
get up they're just hanging out and
they're just walking back and forth they
this guy had cowboy boots on
leather pants and this ferrari
red jacket and gloves and his hair was
all and he's just
there he he pulled his car up and he's
there to answer any questions you have
god damn but some some have such stupid
money like
you might like them chin those lexus um
forget they're what they're called
they're super rare they're super car lf
uh
i love you i love alexis by the way i
don't know but no i can't stand them but
um
because it's just i just don't [ __ ] with
anything uh not german or european oh
really i don't touch them what would be
good apparently that's nice none of this
stuff's good for you but um
like those cars are super rare and
there's five of them and it was all from
the same owner [ __ ] and we talked to the
guy why the [ __ ] would you buy five of
these he's like because there's there's
only like i don't know 50 of them he
found five it helps the market out so i
can i dictate the market when i sell it
these four will go oh
that's pretty dope i was like oh my god
you got money dude yeah
how much are those
uh i mean
that one's 370 you're not touching it
for probably under 700 right now and and
it's just it's crazy fast or what would
it be fast and i've supposedly again i
don't give a [ __ ] because japanese but
um supposedly the drive is insane like
greg was like you talk all that [ __ ]
about japanese cars but i guarantee you
drive the thing you're to try and buy
one you don't give a [ __ ] about that
thing i do i take a my gt2 or i take a
fry over you're just prejudiced against
it yep can't stand them but i mean can i
talk about it i can't talk into it at
all nope
if anyone's going to talk man it would
be greg and i was just like no i'm good
dude
greg's got his knowledge
oh what yeah
but you're saying [ __ ] it it's japanese
does that do anything for you
it's a toilet you like it you like yeah
i like the lines i like to blow out ass
at the back you're a car guy brad no not
from it but i'm fascinated with i will
say like i was telling you before
i i really appreciate fashion now
because i watch some of those shows and
i see how talented those [ __ ]
are you see those people they are some
of them are are so gay it's like the the
way they dress if they're just they show
up in a costume they're such unique
characters
holy [ __ ] are they artists wait a
fashion where you go to fashion show
there's a show called there's a show
called next fashion and and these are
the oh they're already established
fashion designers but they'll make them
do [ __ ] like you know they'll just be
like you have two days to come up with
yeah uh uh underwear or two days to come
up with uh sportswear or a suit and dude
they are
well there it is yeah okay they are so
[ __ ] good insanely good and they fail
too i mean it's from uh
we're right he's amazing he's a designer
himself yeah great guy and [ __ ]
hilarious it sounds like it's similar to
uh right here what's her name heidi
klum's uh project runway yeah yeah yeah
it also it also makes me proud of my
country because we live in a society
where people like that who would in like
in afghanistan that guy would be thrown
from a [ __ ] roof and and we're just
here in afghanistan that guy was a folk
uh singer
and they murdered him he was a comedian
dude he was a tic he made tick tock
songs they tortured him and then they
killed him because they said we don't
want that type of music and they they
they executed a comedian and and those
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you see people like
this who are primarily gay very
different uh and incredible and they
make this the world that we live in
whether you like no or not they they
make the world
everything correct everything correct
because they're artists yeah and and
when you have a society that takes
people like that and throws them from
roofs or imprisons them or whatever
you're a [ __ ] idiot because your
society is actually weaker and not
interesting yeah you know so anyway it's
pretty cool man to watch what they do
i heard our boy tim kenny gotten some
[ __ ] this week didn't hear about this no
bunch of uh former military were like
saying like you know going hard in the
paint on tim but it sounds like tim was
trying to help and he gathered a bus of
like two buses of people who were
stranded out there
and then he was trying to get them
through to through the airport but what
it did it caused a four-hour delay at
least to get everybody through so some
families didn't get through so some
people are so pissed
but it sounds like he was trying to help
yeah
it's a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] is
gonna make a lot of people really angry
look at him i look man the guy went
there so [ __ ] off he's doing the best he
can how many people he saved dude they
said he drove two bus filled with people
trying to get out
but it just doesn't work like they gotta
they go through the process and make
sure they're you know they're not
terrorists coming here yeah
finding them is a big problem getting
them on is a big problem
right when i get on the ground we're
doing a reconnaissance of a new rat line
a spot that we're planning on every
trying to smuggle some more people
through and around the car looking on
top of the building there's taliban
listening post opposition posts with
trained observers that were looking into
the airfield to try and identify where
all of the american forces were that a
sniper rifle up there obviously their
job was to be prepared to deal death
against american forces
and if afghans are trying to get out
uh
saying the operation had to be shifted a
few hundred meters behind another
building so those guys wouldn't shoot at
us
okay they said a variety of people
include american citizens christians
orphans pilots teachers were rescued
during the missions i'm sorry people are
upset at our guy tim kennedy he's
captain america man yeah
i think the issue was by him doing that
like going rogue this i don't know the
exact situation but from what i hear
from these haters is him going rogue it
caused them to like have to focus on his
people but then other families didn't
get out right but it sounds like he got
a bunch of people out
so how can be mad at the guy
i don't know anything anything tim does
i'm gonna be a fan of so oh tim can do
no wrong yeah for me anyway i mean i i
just know that he went there
was like on his own dime like i mean he
went to afghanistan to go help people
talk about putting your money where your
mouth is the guy's got kids
oh yeah he's
he he
he he walks
the talk and
i always admire people like that
what'd you do this weekend chin
oh my god it's my favorite time of year
football's here football football
football's right around the corner and
draftking sportsbook is official
sportsman partner of the nfl and ufc and
with the nfl returning draftkings is
giving you guys new customers 200 and
free bets instantly when you bet on one
dollar or more on any football one game
the first week you bet listen up because
you don't want to miss this head to
draftking sportsbook app right now place
a bet of one dollar or more on any week
one game to receive 200 in free bets
instantly my bronco is playing the
giants we're about to beat that ass if
sportsbooks is not available in your
state draftkings still has huge cash
prizes for grabs all season long with
their daily fantasy contest and for week
one draftking has given all new
customers a free shot at one million
dollar top prize nothing has the
excitement of watching game like having
a free shot at a million dollar top
prize download the draftking sportsbook
app now use promo code fighter to
receive 200 in free bets when you place
a one dollar bet on any football game
and get a free shot at one million top
prize with your first deposit that's
promo code fighter for limited time only
at draftking sportsbook official sports
better partner of the nfl must be 21 or
older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
only new customers don't leave minimum
five dollar deposit one dollar wager
required one per customer restrictions
fly see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details gambling problem call 100
gambler in indiana 109
with it you know what man sometimes when
i get in the show like yellowstone
ozark
game of thrones
i don't have time to cook man i don't
mess up my flow i'm trying to binge
watch these episodes but i need food i
need snackies and i want it brought to
my house yep i get lazy when i'm so into
a show thank god for grubhub because
grubhub works hard to serve restaurants
so they can work hard to serve you all
right we got a little deal for you today
grow hubs do a little extra for your fam
at panera get a free delivery perk on
your first order from panera bread of 15
or more order through grubhub app or
online grubhub we serve restaurants this
episode of the fighter and the kid is
brought to you by
on it on it supplements the best god
damn supplements in the world i've been
a proud support of them for over eight
years i'm thick but i'm healthy thick
ass my doc y'all ask my frickin doc one
things i like to do is take great
supplements and that's where on it comes
in play all right what do you need man
you need total gut health super
important you need krill oil joint oil
we got creatine glutamine we have the
mood and sleep if you sleep troubles we
got the keto collection the keto kids
back by the way i've been keto for
almost over eight days now so week in a
day i feel okay not gonna lie to you i
feel just okay it's been tough uh anyway
we have uh protein powders the bes my
some of my favorite protein powders we
have uh coffee they got workout gear for
you we got mc2its mct oil we got um
streaming fitness if you still don't
want to go to a gym you want to do it
from home on it in 30 we got on it 30
kettlebell workouts morning mobility on
it streaming fitness programs barbell
body weight durability kettlebell steel
club steel mace we got it all battle
ropes sandbags you can save 10 off
everything i've just told your thick ass
about go to onit.com fighter for ten
percent off
he went to afghanistan and he came to my
show i went there i went to see chapelle
embroidery in breo it's awesome oh
that's awesome how was your show it was
great it was fun yeah it was a lot of
fun your favorite club
yeah i love that damn club good club
yeah that's a great club
the acoustics man you know sure it's
really good in there
you've done you've done buffalo oh yeah
two planes yeah it's a beast to get
through yeah i took a train you took a
trance so you went to from manhattan how
long did the church i did the gotham i
did a train to syracuse and then trained
uh healing see i can't do that was when
i was a younger man and didn't have all
the kids and it was
it was tough but even the trainer bummed
me out
i'm about to go to the plane's train
station oh two planes are you going this
weekend brian no i'm going uh two weeks
yeah right september 9th too yeah when
we're in salem but good club you liked
it right loved it great club great food
great hotels there yeah
what what i'll tell you stan i forget
it's haunted though and you'll find out
because on the haunted tour and that's
how i found out the driver dropped off
your what's it are doing this look cool
haunted [ __ ] here man i stayed at that
well i didn't know it's where they
booked us you know they don't give a
[ __ ] about ghosts and i go
uh
like where's the tour go around buffalos
dude there's a lot of old [ __ ] here in
buffalo it was the toy actually starts
it
yeah where i'm dropping off he's the
first stop on the hunt to tour
the place hunt as [ __ ] me and jay were
so scared we slept together slept with
the lights on oh this was that was
nuts to butts is that right oh yeah it
was scary you said your closet kept
opening or something my closet kept
opening who knows yeah it doesn't scare
me yeah so with the lights on or what
you don't get scared of that [ __ ] you're
good you're fine in fact if it's haunted
i'm gonna definitely stay there and if i
and i'll stay in the most haunted room
well wherever they put you up that's
probably it
you roll like that you know when they're
like oh don't stay in that room i want
that room please
why turn all the lights why is that i
enjoy that you never really hear
anything happening either yeah like name
the last time someone's like dude i was
in that [ __ ] ghost slash my wrists
and i'll stay there
they never do anything they scare you
i'm with you
i just can't sleep yeah it'd be hard for
me to i can't sleep like like if we were
to go in there just like to see the [ __ ]
and like watch whatever eerie things it
does yeah but like like to sleep in
there yeah i i just don't want the
negative vibes if someone's like hey man
you know the last girl who stayed here
died i thought i don't want to do it so
court my boy court who did our old
studio he brought a
a big container that was found on a
haunted ship in lake erie it was a big
container just a big weird container
like the kind of container a human body
you can fit in move around in with a and
all it had was one opening which was
this
this lid like you name the kind of lid
you put on a pot it was a lid that you
would put on it was the weirdest [ __ ]
thing right
and i'm i
don't buy any of this but i would hear
sometimes and so would my my ex-wife she
would hear a baby crying in there
and she would hear noises
and
so one day we had in this back room and
she wouldn't go in the back room and she
wanted to get rid of it she's like i
don't like that room i'm not putting
yeah why not just do a little bit so i
was like no so i was alone one day it
was nighttime and i walked in that room
and i pulled the lid open i put my head
in it and i closed my eyes
and i did feel the hair is raised in the
back of my head yeah a little scared i
got a little skin yeah because i don't
know why i even have that in the house
just get a [ __ ] restoration hardware
because i enjoy that stuff because you
you like you like to go the distance
yeah i just not worried your wife and
kids that's haunted you know yeah that's
fine
[ __ ] with my kids see what i do
if you're a guy
[ __ ] with my kids what are you gonna do
to a ghost i'll punch it in this [ __ ]
face and i'll go consult a book on
demonology and i'll figure out what i
got to do but buffalo the the great food
out there like the place the original
the buffalo no buffalo wings that's what
they do out there my dad my dad the
original buffalo place ain't great but
there's other great ones so my dad when
he worked at a bank they used to when
you got transferred to buffalo at the
branch there you're like [ __ ] no
and he said literally everyone that
would get transferred to buffalo and
they were like they would they would
retire there they would stay there
because it's so nice town it's home town
it's just yeah there was talk of that
you know their their pride enjoys the
buffalo bills who i played uh three
seconds for but they uh
they're talking about because that's
everything orchard park buffalo bills
that's their [ __ ] pride and joy
they're talking about buffalo relooking
to austin that was the rumor
awesome bills
it would be really weird because they've
been the buffalo bills forever for as
long as i can but they but they refuse
to build a new stadium like so
everything's there's old why what do
they do they just somebody buys them and
brings them over to austin no no or or
the city of austin takes them in and
then the the owner of the team uh ralph
uh wilson i think the wilson family
they'll just relocate it they're not
gonna sell i would almost start my own
new lead is that the hotel
oh you start your own nfl no no no no no
no that's a brilliant start my own team
oh yeah oh yeah because that's so easy
so you know how teams work no so there's
whatever 32 teams in the league yeah all
have to vote yeah it's a nightmare wait
hold on do you think it's that easy to
start your own team start them on team
yeah do that you have to do is come up
with a name yeah and then also you'll be
a billionaire there's that too oh that's
that's that part and then you have to
have all the infrastructure the stadium
all that stuff so i can't just and then
and then the the governor and the
commission everything has to pass it's a
nightmare that's why so it's a step
process it's a nightmare i can't be like
let's call these guys the
[ __ ]
runners brian callan just can't do it no
report puts austin on the short list
yeah austin's blowing up
members of this threatening to move if
they were given a stadium they're just
it's just a move to get a new stadium
they have like maybe the best fan base
yeah the fan base that donates money to
the other team like when something
happens or like a fan gets hurt they'll
like donate money yeah really whether
it's the steelers whoever it is
what is your team
broncos from denver for god's sakes
broncos and then just by default being
la it's the rams
the broncos isn't jay's team is it no
raiders he's raiders guy yeah jason
right he's a weird kid
just a weird difficult human being
that makes sense
you like bo jackson which is fine but
both played like three years
that makes sense it's so weird he's a
weird kid
he knows his [ __ ] though weird kid okay
don't get an argument with him about
this he when he argues or has a point of
view
he has done his homework
i love conversations with jay me and him
got each other's face over the new kanye
album i it's upright to me he's true oh
yesterday when you guys did or sunday
morning yeah i could hear y'all yelling
i was like they're literally arguing
over the world i ever saw you guys get
into when jay was like i don't consider
having kids uh for a mother i don't
consider that like that much of a job
and you were like you [ __ ] it you
guys got i got to say heavy yeah we're
about to fight i was crazy yeah what
about we're not like the [ __ ]
gianni and christian family whether you
[ __ ] hit each other with a damn yeah
we don't play like no
or whatever oh yeah we'll go nose no
he's not backing down no what what what
did you fight about the kanye app yeah
that's a great thing i'm a drake fan
he's a kanye fan and i just the album's
all right i'm waiting this long it's all
right you're not gonna listen to it
cruising down the street in your car no
jay's like we didn't make [ __ ] pop
music i'm like yeah but you want people
like your music this [ __ ] is weird and
it's like super religious like there's
26 on switch nobody wants those 26 songs
so yeah [ __ ] who it is it's 21.
each i don't know where you're going to
play it but they released at the same
time right there no drake no it's friday
night okay
that's all everybody's waiting for
connie released then
who's going to do better i wonder
i bet drake does because he it's more
like
i never i've never been i've been i'm
way more into kanye than drake i i went
down both rabbit holes and i think
drake's a little commercial for me
because that's very kind
of different that's
monsters at what they foreign both of
them yeah yeah so you can like both of
them i like both of them i'm just not
gonna like i listen to the connie album
we listen all the way back from la jolla
i just did last night from to the you're
listening while you're playing uh nba
gym or
trying to see if i'm gonna like him yeah
but i i listen to drake and i i get why
he's commercial like i get why people
like him he's doing on purpose
yeah whereas i listen to kanye and
connie's always trying to do something
different yeah that's what i appreciate
yeah connie goes all all out there yeah
i think he's kind of different angles i
guess you could technically say kanye's
just more of an artist but he's a guy
that listens to like so much music so he
finds the inspiration for everything
that's why his favorite super innovative
man yeah he's [ __ ] you know he's
always been really innovative
mm-hmm who was this would you tell me
the story about when he was a kid
and he was uh he was like he he oh i
think it was jamie foxx did you tell me
the story about jamie foxx where he
hit gold digger and he was like
recording it was like three in the
morning calls you know jamie foxx at
three in the morning is come down here
and jamie's like what and he goes we're
we're oh yeah he comes down and uh jamie
you know jamie's older and kind of
famous and kanye had a backpack on like
young and he sang it and kanye goes
that's not good man he goes do this
again he goes but just let it go stop
stop thinking so much you just gave them
no it wasn't gold digger it was uh
their other song okay yeah but yeah but
that's the way you were talking about it
was just like the [ __ ] kids
exactly what do you want people that
kanye's influence as far as
fashion designers and artists the
fashion designers no not fashion
designers that's interesting it's dude
it's i mean it's the who's who like yeah
really head of louis vuitton gucci like
he influenced everybody wow yeah or gave
them their first opportunity like he's a
monster that's the difference with him
it's just he's just he's just such an
artist on another level he moves the
[ __ ] world moves
he's it's always on his mind man but i'm
definitely looking more forward to the
drake album yeah yeah
i get it
what do you got for us jen
all right and also i
i went to vegas for one day on saturday
oh yeah that's right yeah for one day or
one night literally okay one one day one
night so i left saturday morning
and then stayed there saturday night and
left sunday morning to fight companion
but i wanted to ask you guys i'm 44
right now yeah not for you my friends
right so we went for uh my friend my
girlfriend's sister's birthday and other
friend's birthday they went to omni
uh nightclub yeah
we paid 500 bucks each
right and then music started pumping
everything i'm like
i can't be here you're too old i left in
15 20 minutes right you fell down i felt
like yeah
unless you're single too and you're like
trying to get those back that's what i'm
saying girls
what are you doing and even then exactly
even how are you going to do it
it's [ __ ] tough i hate that stuff so
much too old for it yeah i i i can't be
bothered it's just not for me it's
annoying to me that they're like can you
also feel kind of like a loser like you
paid all this money uh dude
i'd rather be at my house with a bottle
of good whiskey and switch tv there was
like hot girls but there's a lot of
dudes and there's dudes behind us and we
rented or you know we got that spot for
a six thousand dollar table yeah and
then the guys behind us started dancing
and started moving up my chair i'm like
i'm gonna get into a fight or something
something's gonna happen you know yeah
15 minutes that's my gift right there
yeah i know
you've never been a club guy at all
that's called a depreciating asset
where'd all your money go well i had
bottle services the worst one i see like
older guys with that they get order the
bottles they're like six thousand dollar
bottles they have the sparklers on top
oh god dude how much the girls on the
dude who's
shoulders who hurt you bro yeah like
what what what did you do when you were
younger you need to do this i saw a guy
and then there's this girl and she was
doing the same thing with the drinking
it was like one of those clubs in vegas
and he
took like a stack of like i don't know
what it was twenty dollar bills and went
there that made it rain whoa oh no
oh yeah my my yeah it's my with the
belly it's a bomb
now that's sad when they're that [ __ ]
old it's a disaster man
i but also if your plans get chicks with
that money just go you don't you know
what kind of [ __ ] you get into for six
grand at a strip club
if you want to get crazy that's where
you spend yes daddy i mean let's just
cut to the chase yeah what are we doing
if you're trying to that's the guy he
wants but but he wants he wants the
flesh he wants what he wants he wants to
find he wants everybody to see yeah
people well he might have been like a
nerd growing up and he didn't have the
money and then now he wants now he has
money
my friend my dad's friend made a lot of
money he was a total nerd in high school
and he shows him his high school reunion
he's
50 something and he shows up at his high
school union with the most expensive
ferrari he can buy and my dad goes how'd
he go and he goes he goes
i'm still a nerd the domino nerd with
the proof
it was great i'm still nervous
with the ferrari that's what they did
work out that's awesome
what do you got jen all right this is
the first one apparently there was a
bomb threat at the jake paul italian
woodley fight um someone called in an
hour and a half beforehand saying that
they had 17 or 15 different devices in
there
so
that could have been a disaster if that
was actually taken seriously but i think
some haters just hating on jake paul
trying to ruin this fight of course and
but i mean the amount of trouble this
guy could get into for this kind of
prank
they'll find them yeah so i mean they
called the you know bomb sniffing dogs
and stuff like that they didn't notice
anything so that's why they let the
fight kill you you're going to jail
yeah you're also wasting a lot of
resources and like it's so stupid yeah
it also didn't work you know that's the
other yeah
well there's that and i just saw this
recently nicole scherzinger she's
working out in a pussycat dolls
jesus
she's like in her 40s
i knew her a little bit and uh
actually
she's so beautiful
oh yeah
she works on a bikini like that
at least for this video she's a gorgeous
man she is so filipino her husband is uh
that was the f1 schumacher i think
really he has all the money in the world
and all the cars yeah it's a little
awkward i'd probably say you know
i personally don't do that but also
about the body that body yeah you're
tripping but she's amazing
god dog she's
and how cool is this
so this is i think how many years 23
million
43 million your 43 million year old
fossil was found and it was a whale
with legs a jackal's head and it could
live in the sea and land well don't [ __ ]
around with it i'll tell you that much i
think i don't know if that's a jackal's
head but it'll bite your [ __ ] head
off thirteen hundred pounds too
huge and that was discovered in egypt
recently
yeah the animals back then were so sick
yeah and back then there were things
that were even bigger than that so oh
yeah
like that megalodon shark and just be
like oh that's cool i'm gonna bite you
in half
all right
some of cats current events
uh i don't know if you guys have seen
this in any of the comments that you
guys have on your social media but the
nahi tweaking like people started
commenting on everything nah he tweaking
it's from uh little nasdaq's
commenting about tony hawk's thing
having blood on his board using his
actual blood um and tony hawk said now
he's tweaking no no a little nausea
commented nah he's not he's tweaking
what's that i bought something like you
know what does that mean like he's
saying tony hawk's tweet yeah no
how do i explain this
hold on here it's all because montero
artists christian you're young
it's all because of the macho artist
apparent quasi beef skateboard legend
tony hawk the whole thing seemingly
began what brought to little nasdaq's
attention that hawk was selling
skateboards decorated with paint infused
with blood
uh now that tony hawks was really scared
with his blood pain on them and there
was no public outrage y'all ready to
admit it y'all were never
actually upset over the blood in the
shoes and maybe you were mad for some
other reason
hugh's critics would possibly have any
bigger problem the fact that he's a gay
black man
uh than the shoes themselves could be uh
he has taken a lot of [ __ ] though for
for a lot of stuff did he does get a lot
of hate
i don't i don't know i don't know if
that's that though but i shouldn't no
and plus remember i don't know much
about this and plus remember the his
shoes had actual
height of kovid
and it was a devil shoe and they said it
was a nightmare and this is that one
this is tony hawk's skateboard like he
has his own skateboard
yeah i don't care about blood
like if it's
i don't care either way yeah i guess i'm
not buying
[Laughter]
a lot of people were like that's the rat
world's still the rap world like the rat
like it's not even the rap world society
is still like i know we live in
hollywood so it's a little different and
everyone we we act like it's not a big
issue but dude listen i've had listen i
i play in [ __ ] midwest and texas and
stuff like that and i have those jokes
referencing gay stuff they don't play
that [ __ ] man yeah they just don't right
it's not up to my control it's just a
lot of people aren't that open-minded
yes
later on the scroll up
uh this is later in the instagram post
by rap tv the page mentioned how hawk is
hawking the custom boards for 500 bucks
and as far as y'all rocking with it and
little knock said nah y'all tweaking
yeah that's how it happened you know
what it's all good publicity for both of
them so there you go
well tony hawk looks like an actual bird
and he's a legend but he's a bird he's a
legend a lot like a bird yeah he looks
like a bird he looks great he looks like
a mean [ __ ] eagle yep
legend though i'm not buying either i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll buy the board
how much is the board 500 bucks
that's a pretty expensive board
yeah can i get by the board anymore are
boards expensive uh a complete board
like like trucks and all that you
usually got like 150. yeah but like for
just the board itself just the deck with
tony 500 that's expensive
yeah
i might i might buy and hang it up in my
house i love tony hawk yeah me too yeah
i remember when he did the 900.
watched it on tv his video game changed
the game yeah what else you got too uh
this is related to it so apparently
after that nahi tweaking started going
viral i guess bradley martin he posted
something and it was like all over his
instagram as well i mean whatever this
is
no one's stronger and
she's she's gorgeous ridiculous
you know
jesus
some hip thrust
man he's so [ __ ] strong he's
weird strong [ __ ] dude shrugging with
900 pounds his bar was bent
oh and ryan garcia but not he tweaking
dude
and and who is that gal i'm just curious
i'm only she tagged in here yeah it
doesn't look like it there's a bunch of
people it's gotta be that way yeah well
let's just make sure everything's all
right let's make sure yeah she has all
her stuff yeah
no i don't think so i'm going to say
oh wow but
wow that's her and her friend
well good for her well you know that's a
good chance and that's when you're
serious
where i come from we call it a nice bum
i don't know yeah i i'm not
i don't notice i'm just all i'm saying
is that she seems like she's a real
athlete you know i don't see curves how
about that well i'm just looking at well
all right and there it is okay well
she's gorgeous yes yes i would say that
i would say we get it you know we get it
i got you there it's not like overly big
either it's just
no it's what's called kind of perfect
i'll be honest with you i mean if you're
into that kind of thing if you're in
that
perfect i mean
yeah that girl got the dumper on her
mm-hmm
back it up and dumped all right chin get
her out of here
um let's go with this one here yeah
how about this parents are ordered to
pay 45 000 worth of porn for
their son because they threw out boxes
of full of his sex toys and porn and
he's 43 years old oh he had a divorce 10
years ago then he moved in with his
parents okay something like that been
tough
is this stevie weeby [ __ ] dude
yeah it sounds like things are
not a tr hey a trove of porno
and toys we're out 10 months later
i mean who knows it could have been
taking up the whole house and they were
like this stuff is in the way
that could be a thing
his dad wrote uh i did not
possess your porn it's gone it has
either been destroyed or disposed of i
may well have missed a few items that
are now in your possession but at this
point if you don't have it it's gone
ditto for your sex toys and smutty
magazines frankly david is your big
favorite getting rid of all this stuff i
agree with the dad yeah
the collection was like 30 grand that's
insane
30 grand but that's okay
but think about this kid suing his
parents like i mean he's not a kid after
living 43 years old like a real
ten years man wow 30 grand you know what
it's a moving out thing he's probably
trying to get started now at 43 and and
that's kind of great can i get his porn
back
now but also who has troves of actual
porn because you can find the internet i
don't know if you can you've got it's
free on there
listen if that doesn't get your rocks
off you got problems i guess you'd
rather have your vhs he's probably got
him labeled magazines right got
everything you know he's got toys and
shits toys
doesn't look like bradley martin no
no his last name is working i like the
frankly david new york frankly david
that's my favorite line
that's exactly
that's what i picture every negative
comment i've ever gotten it's that guy
it's this guy with a leaning gloves on
him
down there that's him down there oh
that's him no the guy oh that's the
parents oh yeah okay no i don't know
that's sick oh that's him no that's
that's not it yeah no that's not him i
think it's just a it's got a wedding
read the articles
it's probably a different picture for
something else yeah
well either way you can it's got to be
that guy with the beast well frankly
david
frankly david we got rid of your porn
you scumbag
on the internet neither have i nor will
i find your attitude towards women to be
very disturbing
women are objects free to masturbate to
they're people created by god just so
yours should be treated with respect
dignity i have to get you out of the
basement your cheeto fingers uh
yeah yeah
yeah all right all right
yeah mom dad that's the dad they look
like mom and dad look like great son's
gonna look like them combined
the way it works what else you got
all right next one is the kanye album
thing
so
he's saying that the album was released
without his permission and then they
they took off the jail two song because
they had teachers
uh marilyn manson and the baby both
canceled and he had him on the song
great song
that's probably the best song on there
jail too interesting that's great uh but
they released it without his permission
yeah they're probably like dude just
[ __ ] release it
and then they put it up there which
usually isn't cool but mm-hmm
the people so yo yo man hold up hold up
hold on you manage your car the second
post west supposed to screenshot the
conversation apparently would debate
himself tell him that the album wouldn't
be coming out and asking if he knew that
his management wasn't clear in the track
when baby de baby said he did it west
africa for the sport yo man was your cap
they tried to stop you from coming in
the people next to you trying to destroy
you but god got a bigger plan
and then the sunday afternoon
apparently i guess chris brown was on
there uh
soldier boy got taken off uh someone
else got taken off why did soldier but
they don't they think that's kanye doing
that and then just trying to be like oh
they did it man i didn't know what
happened why did soldier boy get there
who knows
there was controversy with him before
too no it's not because of that he's
released sponge songs
well speaking of soldier boy he assigned
chet hanks to his record label
so
this guy's the limit man
soldier boy doesn't look healthy
[Music]
sons of anarchy
what do you think tom hanks does when he
sees this
yeah it's just crying it's successful
he's such a sweet guy though chet yeah i
like chat i'm a fan
i think he has a huge enormous fan base
all different walks of life enjoy him
like seeing on social media so i think
he's huge yeah
you think his album would be huge i
think he will be huge because he has
that personality i don't know everyone
likes him chet hanks chet hanks
how huge
like
i think he's going to be big i don't
even think about music is you you still
gotta you know i don't know what his
songs are pretty good
and stuff though
yeah i'm sure i mean and produced really
well i hope so and soulja has some
[ __ ] hits man yeah
okay looking dude
yes she is uh this is not that new but i
thought this was pretty crazy
this is called cash in transit
drivers and this guy was an ex-cop a
retired cop who's driving and then also
someone else who's a security on this
little what do you what do we call this
the cit truck
and so the robbers try to get them and
this is in pretoria south africa oh i've
seen this video saw this i haven't seen
it oh yeah i'll play with the video oh
this was their [ __ ] oh there's them
trying to shoot out yeah you saw this
these guys
this guy even looks like like james bond
he's a bad [ __ ] man he's so he's
doing invasive driving mm-hmm so they're
just chilling
you see that [ __ ]
they're shooting at him right now yep
toyota land cruiserweight to kill him
bulletproof windows yeah they're
straight up trying to kill them [ __ ] to
take the money
watch them get that gun up watch this
this gun is sick this dude doesn't know
what to do
that guy's panicking
yeah yeah his eyes got way bigger are
they trying to rub him off the road too
yeah
they tried to kill him man look at that
[ __ ]
boom oh it's that car there yeah
so now you get the gun going
this guy's up
come on you [ __ ]
i love this and he's driving really well
too under stress oh yeah he's a badass
watch this ready watch this
they're trying to knock him off the road
yeah they're just chasing them and
shooting them
[Music]
he lives fast
you're on the right i don't know when
people are actually trying to kill you
it sucks
yeah he's trying to control his
breathing like you could tell
you can't right the the badass just now
there goes another spot here did he honk
his horn
[Music]
[Music]
all those cars are they carry oh yeah
dude they're [ __ ]
so they're not ducking or anything
they're just like holy [ __ ] dude this
guy and the guy gets away
[Music]
unfortunately
no what do you mean unfortunately i'm
saying the homeboy oh no yeah so you'll
see here i'll just fast forward so
near the end he tries to find a spot to
wait for him
right
to wait for him with his gun yes watch
you'll see him
so he found a spot here and then he
grabs his gun
opens the door this guy's like uh here's
the gun dude he's like yeah come at me
he's gonna give me damn
but the guys eventually they took off
without getting because they they
realize this guy's serious yeah this
guy's [ __ ] [ __ ] around holy
[ __ ]
dude that remind the
the aunt of those kids that i was in the
car crash with the uh the ant reached
out and i'm going to meet up with the
kids in the ant hell yeah yeah hell yeah
that was what they say i think it's in a
different language it's going to be
tough yeah uh where they are they're not
south africa they're speaking afrikaans
for money they just they did his other
friend was like this
his eyes were like who's there he's like
getting that gun
he's like get the [ __ ] useless no i'm
like it's not for you dude yeah it's not
for you you saw how i acted yeah we
can't use you
what else you got jen i think that's
pretty much it that was awesome
yeah
oh no this this
i love this
are we able to oh this yeah yeah cause
it's it's him doing a cover
it's a little kid
[Music]
oh what a little badass
[Music]
and that fortnight t-shirt
that was dope
you keep going
someone said do that
[Laughter]
i'm doing it man i like how he knew
exactly where to go to the black
neighborhood
all right that was good yeah there you
go kids hi kids september 9th to 11th
i'll be in san jose with the boys
chappelle lace out lacy's and david
lucas san jose improv that's september
9th through the 11th and the big boy san
antonio texas one show september 24th
which is a friday one show september
25th which is saturday at the bud light
event center and then mama i will see
you september 30th through october 2nd
denver colorado comedy works downtown
other one on there is las vegas october
7th through the 9th at the new wiseguys
in las vegas helium comedy club see you
in buffalo september 9 to 11 september
23 25 i'm in denver colorado with the
comedy works downtown september 30th
october 2nd
uh oh he does these graphics i say he
came to la jolla oh
illinois september 30th to actually same
dude i forget the guy's gentleman's name
who gave him oh yeah how dope this is a
candle this guy makes wow he can do any
shoe wow how dope is that
i like that
smell that daddy does it smell good oh
man it's nice it smells like feet
uh-huh
all right i'm going to catch a plane
kids i love you
no
the east coast september uh
eighth i'll be in san francisco at
cobb's comedy club uh just a one night
or wednesday 8pm and then october 7th
through 9th tampa florida at side
splitters boom
boom love you guys bye